Thanks for having me. I think since we're in a classroom
setting, as Mike said, we can make this very interactive. I'
ll make a few opening remarks and sketch out what we did and
we did it as quickly as I can with the clock back there
reminding me what time it is and then would love to take
your questions on any aspects of this. I'll start at the end
actually because when GM went public that day I had agreed
to co-host CNBC and was sitting on the set of CNBC as the
various GM executives and the floor people and bell rang and
the first share was traded and all that, and it was an
amazing moment after all the ups and downs and all the work
and all the effort even though we had felt very good about
what we had done to actually see it validated by the market
was really quite a moment.
Before I go back in time, I do want to just amplify on Mike'
s recognition of Clay Calhoun who is sitting over here
because you'll all want to read this book, because Clay is
very prominently mentioned in it. He is actually in the
index, but I want to just read one paragraph. This came up
in the middle of the frenzy when we were trying to get
Chrysler and Fiat all on the same page and they had
different sense of projections and we basically said, "You
guys have a weekend to figure this out," and I didn't want
to spend the weekend in Detroit. Ron Bloom, my deputy, didn'
t want to spend the weekend in Detroit so we sent Clay and
another fella called Brian Osias, so this little paragraph
begins on Saturday morning: "By 11 am on Saturday morning,
Osias and Calhoun convened more than two dozen Fiat and
Chrysler executives and advisors around the large table in
Chrysler's 15th floor boardroom. The executives were almost
all middle-aged industry veterans. Osias was 32-years old
and Calhoun was 26 and both looked younger than their years.
We're going to sit at this table until we're done, Calhoun
announced." There is much more about Clay here. You should
all get this book and read it. I'm sorry Clay, I didn't mean
to embarrass you like that but Clay and I worked together at
Quad Wrangle and he was a superstar there and so when I went
to Washington to take this job and he asked me if we were
looking for help and I said, "We're looking for all kinds of
help," and I was really delighted that he joined us and like
all the rest of our team he did a fabulous job.
Let me, just as I said, try to do two things in a short
amount of time and so I'll speak reasonably quickly and then
we can open it up. Let me just give you a quick chronology
for those of you who didn't follow all this all that closely
and I can't blame you for not and then, let me give you a
few of the takeaways from the project that I would love you
to all leave the room thinking about. And then, as I said,
we can have a discussion. I think probably the most of you
remember that sort of first big public event in the auto
crisis in November of 2008 when the three executives flew to
Washington to testify in front of the Congress in their
separate planes. That's the part everybody remembers. What
people don't remember as well is they showed up having GM
and Chrysler particularly having kind of frankly suddenly
discovered that they were about to run out of money, having
just as suddenly told the Bush administration that they were
running out of money and then being sent to Congress by
Secretary Paulson and appearing there with essentially no
plan, no idea what they were going to do with money and no
recognition of any sort of culpability in the fact that they
had run out of money.
There was a lot of
[inaudible] at the end of 2008. Obviously, there had been a
presidential election, it was a lame duck administration.
There was a banking crisis going on but President Bush and
Congress ultimately just failed to act. They just couldn't
pull themselves together to do anything about autos at that
point. President Bush, in my opinion, quite correctly made a
decision that the auto companies were not going to fail on
his watch and so one of this kind of SWAT teams of ex-
Goldman guys that he brought in sort of pulled together in
December of 2008 and provided bridge loans of about $17
billion to GM and to Chrysler to get them over to the end of
year, get them into 2009 when the new team was going to
arrive and would hopefully then have the time to band with
just kind of the energy frankly to address the problem. And
as I said, I think given the situation at that point, the
end of an eight year presidency, a lot of very tired people,
I think the Bush people did about as good a job as you can
do under the circumstances.
President elect Obama then of course realized that he had to
deal with this problem and after some deliberation decided
they would set up a separate task force to do this. There
were two reasons really for that. One, they knew that the
economic and financial crisis was going to occupy all of the
people who had the traditional jobs of under-secretary of
this or assistant-secretary of that within treasury, within
commerce, within the White House. And the second reason they
did it, which is an interesting reflection on how our
government works is that we had no auto expertise in the
government really. For that matter, we didn't have any
industrial expertise and I don't say that critically, but in
this country relative to some European countries and other
countries we really have tried to stay out as a government
from the industrial sector and so part of that is not really
having people whose job it is to understand industry in
general or even specific industries. And so, there are a
couple of people on the Commerce Department who kind of
monitored auto imports and we later found out that there are
a few people over at the FED who actually were pretty good
at forecasting auto sales in general but there was really
nobody in the entire government who knew anything about
autos and of course I didn't know anything about autos
either but that's a different matter.
So they decided to set up this team and they did come to me,
and so you may say why did they come to me, and that would
be a very valid question. The short answer is because Tim
Geitner and Larry Summers; the two guys who Clay and I and
the rest of our team worked for directly as well as
obviously indirectly with President they had the view that
this was not a management job. We were not being hired to
run these companies, we were being hired to decide what the
next new car should be or what cars they should make, it was
really a financial restructuring exercise and a private
equity exercise for that matter. We were being hired to
basically look at these companies and figure out how to take
them from the disastrous place they were and restructure
them into something that could be viable, and by the way, we
knew that we were going to be making a very significant
additional investment of government money and so it was a
private equity exercise in the sense that we were investing
all of your money, tax payers' money and we needed to try to
figure out whether this was a good investment or not and be
able to tell the President and his other senior advisors in
the White House what we thought was likely to happen.
They looked at me and Clay and the rest of us who ultimately
arrived as a restructuring team. I was not the most
experienced restructuring guy in the world either but
because of my political involvement they felt that since
this was going to be an exercise that occurred in the
political arena, even though there was a great commitment to
having it being done in a thoughtful way that having someone
who had a sense of the politics of it all would be helpful
as well as the hopefully the financial skills. We were on an
incredibly tight timeframe because as I said, they had been
given a relatively small amount of money, $17 billion to get
them through essentially the first quarter of 2009 and
through the end of March, so I didn't really even start
doing anything until January of 2009. My appointment wasn't
announced until late February of 2009. The rest of the team
really didn't come together until early March of 2009 and so
we were operating on this really tight timeframe, tighter
than any project I think I have ever worked on and with a
relatively small team. We ended up with 14 of us; mostly
people like Clay and me who had come from Wall Street,
because they wanted to serve but some policy people as well
and that by the standards of what we were being asked to do
was an exceptionally small team. I remember one of my
reservations about taking the job was how are we going to
find the people and get the people we needed to do this and
Larry Summers said to me in one of my early meetings, "How
many people do you think you need?" and I said, "In a
private sector context I think 50. Here, maybe 15," and he
said, "My whole staff is only 19." And I said, "Well, that
may be but we need 15 to do this job," so we ended up having
14. We got essentially what we needed but it was, as I said,
I think JP Morgan you mentioned, David Hopper was working on
this and Morgan Stanley and they had dozens and dozens of
people, so it was a very lean team.
From the beginning, there were two principles that the
President, Larry Summers and Tim Geitner decided that were
really critical to the success of our efforts. The first was
that the only money that we wanted to put in and hoped to
put in was in the context of a fundamental restructure and
make the companies viable. They decided and I was really
pleased that they did that they didn't want to kick the can
down the road anymore, they didn't want to try to paper it
over, they didn't want to try to just get to the next
election. Whatever we did, they wanted it to be something
that made these companies viable again. And the second
important principle that we established early on and they
stood by throughout this was shared sacrifice, that this was
not going to be done on the backs of the UAW alone, it was
not going to be done on the backs of the creditors alone or
on the dealers or the suppliers but that we were going to
try to get everybody to the table and get everybody to
recognize that they were not the only ones who were being
asked to sacrifice. And both of those principles turned out
to be very important ones.
We plunged in. As I have acknowledged, I didn't know
anything about autos, so we approached this with fresh eyes.
We've had every expert wanted to come and tell us their
views about the auto industry. We met with an awful lot of
them, we listened to everybody's thoughts, we pushed back.
We certainly spent time with the companies. This is all sort
of now in March of 2009 because we knew that by the end of
March, the President had to tell the country what he was
going to do about the auto situation. And by March 25th or
so we had pretty much the essential elements ready for the
President to decide.
The toughest decision that the President had to make really
was whether to save Chrysler or not. We knew pretty well
that we were going to save GM. GM was too big, too important
and what we've thought of as a real company that needed to
be saved. Chrysler was a tougher call. It was, as you know
probably the third largest and third of three American auto
companies. It was only a North American player, it had been
owned for seven years by Daimler and then for a couple of
years by Cerberus and had been pretty well hollowed out. It
didn't have single car that was on consumer report's most
recommended list and there was a strong part of our group
that actually made a very passionate and very logical and
analytically sound argument that Chrysler should be left to
fail, that what was capitalism about if not letting weak
companies fail, why was the government putting a lot of
money into an old industry company and I guess I should
recognize that I am in the part of new industry land here
and so maybe you all don't think we shouldn't have saved any
auto companies and put the money in Google instead, but
there was that argument that if the government has limited
dollars which of course it has, they should be allocated to
newer industries that might have greater growth prospects.
On the other side of the argument, the economy was losing
six or seven hundred thousand jobs a month at this point.
The immediate impact of Chrysler shutting down would've been
around three hundred thousand jobs lost; only small part of
those from Chrysler itself but you then had suppliers, you
had dealers, you had all the people who have serviced this
company and so on and while I don't believe that we would've
saved Chrysler simply because of those jobs, as I said, if
we determined that Chrysler was not viable I think the
President would've agreed with a recommendation to let it
liquidate but after a lot of hard work, I think everybody on
the team agreed that Chrysler could be viable and that the
government could give its money back from Chrysler. It was
more a question of whether it was something that government
should do. Among the points that the people who thought
Chrysler should be allowed to go made was that if Chrysler
went out of business, what we learned as we learned about
the industry was that a disproportionate amount of Chrysler
sales would've gone to Ford and GM relative to the foreign
companies, because the product line up of Chrysler minivans
and trucks and things like that were they were strongest
lined the up best with Ford and GM. In effect, we knew we
were going to be a big shareholder in GM, or a big investor
anyway. By letting Chrysler go, we would make the value of
that investment greater but of course then you'd have all
those jobs lost, so it was a very passionate, hard-thought
debate that went really, as I said, right to the President
and to two meetings in the White House on the 25th or 26th
of March and at the end of hearing it all, the President
came down where a slight majority of our group had come
down, which was to provide Chrysler with additional money if
it could meet a series of very tough tests in terms of
concessions, in terms of a business plan that we could back,
in terms of an alliance with Fiat because we didn't feel
that Chrysler could exist simply as a North American player;
we felt that it needed a global alliance and Fiat was the
company that had come forward that we thought made the most
sense. And so, it was still not a done deal but at least all
things being accomplished, the President agreed that we
would save Chrysler.
So, he gave the speech on March 30th that probably all of
you remember in addition to the announcement about Chrysler
and the announcement that we were going to try to save GM
but still had worked to do. He also announced that Rick
Wagner was going to stepping down as chairman of GM. This,
to us, was the most obvious decision that the President had
to make. GM had lost $30 billion of cash in the 15 months of
2008 and the first quarter of 2009. As I said earlier, when
Rick appeared in front of the Senate in November of 2008
there was no plan, there was no sense of responsibility. It
didn't get any better. The plan that GM submitted to us in
February of 2009 still didn't show us that they had a sense
as to how they were going to become profitable and viable
again and we simply believed that under those circumstances,
there needed to be a change in management. Rick is a very
decent hard-working smart guy who is totally dedicated to
the company but we were thinking about this in a private
equity context in which management really does matter and so
we felt and recommended to the President that there be a
change in management and with really almost no discussion,
which is not meant as any disrespect to Rick, the President
agreed with that. Mike was nice enough to hand out an
article I wrote recently about the role of management which
related to Steve Jobs' last leave of absence and I'm happy
to talk about that a bit in the Q & A because one of the
things I've always believed in both the investment banking
and the private equity business is that the jockey is as
important as the horse, that it's important to have a good
business but who the CEO and who the top management team are
is also important and so we felt that we could not really
recommend in good conscience to the President putting more
money into GM unless there was a change in management.
So, as everybody knows we ended up putting both companies
into bankruptcy. A lot of folks said it couldn't be done, a
lot of folks said that we broke bankruptcy law or we made
new law or the heavy hand of government, I'm happy to talk
about all that but needless to say, we believe that
everything we did was in conformity with the law. In fact,
it was litigated all the way to the Supreme Court. I don't
think when I went to Washington, I ever imagined that I was
going to be worrying about Supreme Court decision as part of
my job but there we were, and at the end, it was all
approved in every step of the way and we got GM and Chrysler
in and out of bankruptcy in essentially record time; 42 days
for Chrysler and 39 days for GM.
I think, as you know, since then it's worked out quite well.
We talked about the GM IPO briefly but the GM IPO simply
symbolized the recovery that the two companies have made.
The bankruptcy process was really essential to giving these
companies a fresh start. In the case of GM, we took their
liabilities from $120 billion to $55 billion. We took $8
billion a year of annual operating cost of their North
America division and this was all accomplished by the kind
of shared sacrifice that I alluded to before in which
everybody came to the table willing to make grudgingly. It
was hard thought, it was difficult but in the end willing to
make changes.
I remember one of our earlier meetings with the UAW when Ron
Gettelfinger who was then the president basically said to us
and actually this was in Detroit, at Solidarity House said
to us, "Look, we're willing to do something here because I,
Ron Gettelfinger understand that if we don't cooperate these
companies may disappear but we feel like we've been to
sacrifice in the past," which they had, "and we feel like we
are the only ones who've been asked to sacrifice and we want
to see other people asked to sacrifice." And so, it was that
concept of shared sacrifice that allowed us to make more
progress with the cost structure, the liability structure
these companies then people haven't been able to make
before. A lot of it relates back to that famous saying of
Rahm Emanuel's which actually was not his but he said it
first, but I can't remember which is, "Never let a crisis go
to waste," that we had this atmosphere of crisis, we had
everybody realizing that without pulling together and making
this work, it would be a disaster. And so, we were fortunate
to have that going for us.
One of the other principles that we established early on was
that the government was going to get in and get out as
quickly as possible, it was going to be kind of the opposite
of Vietnam. We didn't want to be mired in the car business
and so we established early on private sector boards for
these companies and we really looked for directors who had
exactly the right skills. It was in an effort to create a
sort of Noah's Ark compendium of two of everything, it was
an effort to put together a mix of former CEOs and private
equity people who really could oversee these companies and
so as you see, GM and Chrysler going forward now, both very
successfully, a lot of the credit goes not only to the new
management teams of the two companies but also to the new
boards of directors who have been really tough and have just
instilled a whole new aura of corporate governance at these
companies. GM in particular had terrible corporate
governance. One of our colleagues liked to; I shouldn't say
this in front of the cameras but liked to speak of the GM
directors in very disparaging terms and happily, we as I
said made those changes. And the new management teams have
done a great job. A lot of these old industry practices,
some of which actually had logic in terms of the structural
problems in the industry led the companies to do things that
made no sense like have too much inventory on the dealers'
lots, like the famous incentive as in the 0 financing and
all that stuff where they couldn't make money in the end.
There were reasons why they did all that, so it wasn't as
crazy as it seemed but by changing their balance sheets and
changing their cost structures, we essentially gave them a
reason to operate in a more logical and rational business
way and that's what they are doing. Inventories are under
control, incentives are under control and most importantly,
through the restructuring we dramatically changed to the
break even of these companies. So GM, prior to restructuring
really couldn't make money unless 16 or 17 million cars a
year was sold in this country which is something that's only
occurred a few times in our history. After the
restructuring, GM could make money in a 10 or 11 million car
sale environment and so standing here today, with car sales
running about 12.5 million, they were actually 11.5 million
for last year, GM last year had its first annual profit
since 2004 and its highest profit since 1999. So even with
car sales still very depressed, GM is making substantial net
income and Chrysler is actually pretty good operating
profits although not yet net income.
And I continue to be very optimistic. If for no other very
simple reason that we need to sell 15 million cars a year in
this country simply to keep the fleet from aging. In other
words, to deal with replacing cars on the road plus a small
addition of new drivers every year it's roughly a 15 million
car sale rate. For the last three years, we've been below
that, well below that in 2008 and so, this is the first time
in history that essentially more cars have been scrapped
than have actually been sold. So that whole situation is not
a long term sustainable one in my opinion and I think car
sales will continue to climb. I think they'll be somewhere
between 13 and 14 million this year and then just keep
going, and given the changes in the cost structure of these
companies, they can make a lot of money as GM already has as
car sales go up even just a little bit because of the
operating leverage that's inherent to them.
Let me quickly run through what I think are the takeaways,
if you kind of want to leave the room with a thought about
what does this all mean. This is what I think it all means
and I think I have about six of them. First, that this
really could not have happened without the President's
insistence on shared sacrifice and only putting money in if
the companies could be viable. That is not intended to be a
political statement or endorsement or whatever. I'm off the
government payroll, that's what I actually believe that
without that kind of support in the face of what a lot of
people thought would be an enormous pressure from labor, for
example, to be less tough, I don't think we could've done
this.
Secondly, we were able to do this; for that reason, we were
able to do this just almost exactly as if we were in the
private sector. As I said, we approached this as a private
equity investment exercise, we made all the same kind of
decisions and did the same kind of analysis that we would've
in the private sector, although obviously under a different
spotlight and I think we, as a result, invested the tax
payer dollars wisely.
Thirdly, as I said before, contrary to what some of you may
have read or think and again, I'm happy to debate it,
everything we did was not only legal but in accordance with
precedent and in accordance with, I think, fair treatment of
all the stakeholders.
Fourth, as I said, management really matters and I mentioned
the decision about Rick. We made a similar decision in the
case of Chrysler that we felt that management was critical
and a key part of the alliance with Fiat and in deciding to
partner up with Fiat was the fact that Sergio Marcioni was
the CEO of Fiat and Sergio, who was not also a lifelong auto
guy had done a great job of turning Fiat around which had
been a very troubled auto company. It had actually done very
poorly in the US in particular which they exited, but Sergio
had done a great job and we really felt that Sergio was a
jockey that we could bet on. And so, we now in Detroit have
this rather interesting situation of the so-called big three
which they now call the Detroit Three because they are not
so big anymore are all being run by people who are not from
Detroit. Two of whom Mulally and Dan Akerson, who is the
current CEO of GM are not auto guys and Sergio, who is
certainly not a typical auto guy or a lifelong auto guy. And
so, even though we certainly got a lot of blowback from the
auto community about who are we a bunch of non-auto guys,
and who is Akerson and all this kind of stuff, I think that
having fresh blood in this industry has turned out to be the
right decision. Bill Ford, who I only met after this was all
over, because Ford really was not under our care, gave a
speech in about I think in 2006, '07, right about time we
brought in Mulally which I mentioned in the book in which he
basically said, "We are an ancilar company and an ancilar
industry in an ancilar town," and it was something that very
few people in Detroit would acknowledge or recognize but
Bill Ford did and made that decision to bring in Alan
Mulally and it was a really smart decision, it was a very
humble decision and I think it was a very important moment
of introspection on Bill's part.
The fifth point I just want to leave you with which is more
of a Washington point but I assume some of you are
interested in or all of you hopefully are interested in how
our political process works is that we could not have done
what we did without the existence of TARP. I'm sure you all
know what TARP is, the $700 billion financial rescue fund
that was passed actually President Bush's watch, even though
President Obama now gets blamed for it but it was probably
the single - I call it the single most important piece of
economic legislation in certainly my lifetime because it
gave the Secretary of the Treasury the ability to deploy
$700 billion. It was actually never all used. I think only
$450 billion was used to save the financial sector and to
save the auto sector where we but $82 billion. Without TARP,
either administration, both administrations would've had to
have gone to Capitol Hill for every appropriation, for every
dollar that went into the banks or that went into the auto
companies and having now spent a good bit of time in
Washington, I have to doubt that the Congress would've never
pulled itself together to appropriate that money in any kind
of timely way and you would've had a meltdown in the banking
sector, we would've not had the money to save the auto
sector and all the consequences that I alluded to before
about Chrysler would've happened except multiplied.
I'm not here to tell you that we shouldn't have democracy,
I'm not here to say that we don't need a Congress but it was
a real eye opener for me how difficult working with Congress
can be and how hard it is to get stuff done and how much
when people blame the President, either President, any
President for the problems of this country. Frankly, they
should be turning a lot of their attention to Congress
because the President really has much less power than you
would imagine. Our founding fathers had a purpose in mind in
establishing Congress at the Capitol, on the top of the Hill
and the President in the White House at the bottom of the
Hill, that wasn't a complete accident. It's just something
we all need to think about. Congress mostly left us alone,
happily. When they finally focused on autos, it was only
because of the dealers. We closed a lot of dealers and
Congress infuriated by that and so in the summer of 2009,
they spent a lot of time having hearings and calling us up
to explain why this dealer was being closed or that dealer
was being closed, stuff that we actually had nothing to do
with and that was being done thoughtfully, but it was sort
of an odd juxtaposition that the onetime Congress decided to
focus on autos it was over dealers, which in our minds were
not the essential part of it.
The last point I wanted to leave you with is that this was
really the first time I had spent a lot of time in the
manufacturing sector. Clay and I did media and telecom stuff
at Quad Wrangle's, most of what I did in my career and we
can have a whole discussion about the manufacturing sector
but I did come away really very much appreciating and even
scared about the state of our manufacturing sector; really
not through our fault but we are competing in a global world
now. We're competing against other countries that are very
good and getting better and better at doing a lot of things
that we used to be at our own level in doing and it's had
its impact on our manufacturing sector. In my opinion, it's
going to continue to.
I'll give you just a couple of quick little anecdotes that
struck me in the course of this that I talk about in the
book. One was talking to Fritz Henderson who was the CEO of
GM after Rick for a while and GM had plants in Mexico, has a
very thriving business China, it has operations in India and
I said, "Fritz, what do you pay outside the US?" So in the
US, the base wage for UAW worker is $28/hour. In Mexico,
they pay $7/hour, in China they pay $4/hour and in India
they pay $1/hour. And I said to Fritz, "So, what's your
productivity like in Mexico?" and he said, "It's at least as
good as the US, maybe better." And so, this is what we're up
against.
The other vignette that stuck in my mind that I talk about
in here was one day; I think it was in March sometime,
Delphi came in to see us, the executives of Delphi. Delphi,
as you all probably know, was GM's parts operation. It was
spun off by GM in 1999. It went bankrupt about three or four
years ago. It was sort of sitting in bankruptcy for several
years and they came in as one of the many suppliers who came
in to see us to tell us they were being crushed by the
problems at GM and Chrysler and could we help them? And so,
they were kind of making their case for help and Delphi is
based in Troy, Michigan. They were very earnest, solid Mid-
Western kind of folks and I'm listening and I don't know why
it popped into my head but at one moment I said, "How many
people do you guys employ?" The numbers are here but the
answer was something like 135000 and I said, "How many of
them are in the US?" and they said, "15000", so Delphi, this
quintessential American company had quietly, carefully,
deliberately moved 90% of its workers offshore.
This is the challenge we face in manufacturing and we can,
again, have a lively debate about whether we should do more
or less to help manufacturing, but I just think we should be
mindful of the fact that it is a challenge.
Let me close, because probably some of you are wondering
what the score card was on our adventures in autoland. I
mentioned that we invested $82 billion in these companies.
If you look at where GM stock is trading now, if you look at
how GM values at stake and
[inaudible] which actually was our second biggest investment
after GM, a bit larger than Chrysler, if you look at the
valuations that are out there on Chrysler equity, US tax
payer, as we sit here today would recover about 85% of the
money that was put up. In other words, a loss of potentially
around $10 billion.
I continue to believe that there is a lot of upside in the
sector. It's had a bump in the road, no pun intended; in the
last few weeks because of the oil price stuff, shares are
down but I think the general trajectory will continue to be
up and so I think we can actually do better than that, but
even if we end up losing $10 billion, I would argue that $10
billion was money well spent to save the sector because no
only would we have lost Chrysler, we would have lost GM, we
would've lost the suppliers, we would've lost actually Ford
because they wouldn't be able to get parts at least for a
while and it would've been an economic calamity akin to what
would've happened if we hadn't saved the banking sector and
I think devastation across much of the Mid-West.
I'm proud of what we did, I'm proud of the President's
decision to do what he did and glad to be here to tell the
story and happy to spend what time we have left on questions
or comments. Sir -
[Inaudible] to what extent you played out and what would
happen under new scenario, because my intuition would say
that we wouldn't stand to lose all that; like the assets are
not going to sit there. They are going to be bought up
either by foreign auto companies or Ford, part suppliers
still need to supply and there is a certain intrinsic demand
for autos, so to what extent do you have this
[inaudible] different ownership and how does that change the
decisions that you guys made?
That's a good question. With respect to the overall decision
to intervene, we honestly didn't have the time and we were
too terrified of what the result would be to sort of say
what would happen if we did nothing. I just gave you a real
capsule at the end of what I think would've happened if we
had done nothing which would've been GM and Chrysler would'
ve run out of money at the end of March of 2009. They would'
ve closed their doors, they would've stopped paying people.
You've got all these grants. They told you that they would
close their doors, just like them without a plan. Do you
think that the CEO
[inaudible].
Can I respond to that? So you knew exactly when they were
going to run out of money?
No, we didn't actually.
You had no idea when?
From having seen the very knitty gritty balance sheets of
these businesses, they had absolutely no idea how much cash
they had.
The alternative is, he knew the government was going to bail
him out, so he needed to spend all that money...
The CFO of GM could not any given day tell us within $500
million how much cash they had. They did not have the
systems to know. As a result, they said they needed $11
billion of cash to operate and they should've been able to
operate $6 billion of cash or some number like that. They
didn't know. They really didn't know.
Do you know? I mean you just told us you are not an auto
guy. Do you know more than the guys who were running it all
their life. It just doesn't seem to be very -
I don't know how many times or how many days but I can tell
you, they didn't have any money. They could not have paid
their people.
I'm sure they didn't have money, but they did that
intentionally.
You think that they did that intentionally?
You were willing to hand them extra money.
You think that GM basically ended 2007 with $30 billion of
cash and spent all that money on purpose so that the
government would bail them out.
You've got $30 billion. Think about it, you've got $30
billion, pay
[inaudible]
Sir, with all due respect, you hijacked my question.
[Laughter]
In fairness to everybody else who paid the $12 to come to
this meeting, why don't I answer this gentleman's question?
The answer is they would've closed their doors, they would
not have been able to pay their people, they would've all
lost their jobs that day. The suppliers were actually in
worse shape than GM and Chrysler because their business had
fallen off just as much but they hadn't got the $17 billion
at the end of 2008, so that's why we heard from the
suppliers. Actually, first thing we in fact did was the
supplier kind of guarantee program which was frankly more
optics than substance because we didn't feel we could help
every company in this industry, but the suppliers were in
tough shape and most of them actually did end up going
bankrupt but restructuring in bankruptcy, but they would've
closed their doors. The dealers would've temporarily closed
their doors and we can debate the number, but I think we
would've had a couple of million people out of work very,
very quickly.
Now, your point is completely right and we did do a lot of
analysis around Chrysler on this point that obviously people
would've picked up some of that business. For example, and
Clay will help me, I think roughly half of the business of a
typical car dealership is actually repairs, it's not selling
new cars. So obviously, people were going to still have
their cars repaired so some of these people would've kept
their jobs and would've been hired back. Some part of a car
dealership is selling used cars, that would've continued.
You are correct that for example, the Jeep line that
Chrysler had we thought was worth a fair amount of money and
would be sold to some European but would they keep making
Jeep in the US or would they simply take the name plate and
make the cars wherever they happened to be based and send
the cars to the US, who knew? So, you're right that there
would've been a gradual process. You would've had a onetime
loss of this huge number of jobs and then a gradual process
of the jobs coming back in one form or another, because as
you implied in your question, the number of cars that would
be sold in US would probably not change very much, it was
just a question of who was going to sell them, but in our
view it would've been a long painful process. There would've
been certainly a permanent loss of American jobs because
Ford was in no position. Ford was worried they themselves
were going to go out of business. They were in no position
to buy anything. So it probably would've been some non-US
entity and we don't know at the end of it how many jobs
would've remained, just like we don't know if we had not
bailed out AIG we don't know what would happen. If we had
not put in the TARP money into those banks on Columbus Day,
that Hank Paulson put the money into, we don't know what
would've happened. We just felt it was an unacceptable risk
to take, not some kind of social experiment to say let's let
Chrysler and GM go out of business or run out of money and
then we'll see what happens. We just didn't feel that was
the responsible outcome and we had an alternative that we
felt was financially viable and relatively small financial
exposure for the American tax payers.
Thanks for coming. You alluded a little bit to the potential
fire struck that the administration had over this
[inaudible] that Unions got over the bond holders. Can you
talk a little bit more about the politics and giving up the
restructuring and dealing with bond holders and how that all
came out?
Can you explain how it's consistent with the bond investment
while you're at it?
Okay. When people raise that issue, they are generally
talking about Chrysler and Chrysler's capital structure
essentially consisted of $6.8 billion of so called secured
debt that was actually a bunch of banks. It was six or seven
banks. There were no bond holders actually technically in
Chrysler and then there was some second and third lien debt
that was held by little bit by Daimler, little bit by
Cerberus, a bunch by the US government and then obviously
there was equity. So, the challenge with Chrysler was that
the $6.8 billion of senior secured debt was not really
secured by anything. It was sort of notionally secured but
Chrysler didn't have $6.8 billion worth of assets. Chrysler'
s value in liquidation was $1 billion or less in our opinion
and JP Morgan would agree with this.
Essentially, the first question was what was the fair
recovery for those banks? The debt was trading at 15 cents
on the dollar, that's roughly a billion dollar valuation. As
I said, our view was that if we simply handed the keys to
those banks which is one way to handle a bankrupt situation,
they would've knocked out more than a billion dollars out
and probably they've acknowledged and when I talked to them
[inaudible], they acknowledged it was actually probably less
they would've gotten out. So we paid them in the end $2
billion of cash basically to go home and it's also normal in
a bankruptcy as you all probably know for the banks not to
get cash but to get more paper, so we actually were
incredibly generous with those banks relative to what they
were entitled to. And in fact, Jamie Diamond at JP Morgan
when I talked him about this months after he said to me, "My
problem is not what we've got. I think we were treated
fairly. My problem is with what the UAW got."
So, let's turn to the UAW and I would start by arguing that
frankly, what UAW got is none of his business. In other
words, he got at least as much, I would argue, substantially
more than he was entitled to get or would've gotten under
any other circumstances. We made a decision; the UAW had a
$12 billion claim against Chrysler for what was called a
VEBA, it was for the famous retiree health care benefits
that you've all read a lot about. The company has actually
to their credit had done a good job before we showed up of
putting a box around these open-ended health care
liabilities and by doing a deal with the UAW in which they
both agreed to put a fixed amount of money into a trust that
would pay these health care costs and in return for that,
that would be all the companies had to pay. There could be
no further retiree health care liability to companies.
In Chrysler's case, it was a $12 billion obligation. They
had funded about $1 billion I think and I think there was
$12 billion left. It's an unsecured claim against the
company. We could've wiped it out. We could've basically
said, "You're down in the capital structure," I hope this
all makes sense to you guys. I assume you're in business
school, hopefully it does. So we said we could've wiped that
out but we felt that if we did that we would simply not have
workers to do this job, that essentially this was all part
of a negotiation and in order to reach some we were the UAW
to make a lot of sacrifices but asking them to wipe out all
the retiree health care funds which would affect obviously
the retirees but also the people who were still working
there was simply a bridge too far and so we converted half
of that into a note and gave them equity for the other half.
And that happened to be 55% of the equity of the company
underneath a huge mountain of debt that was still sitting on
top of it, of US government debt and other debt and our view
was that that equity was not worth a huge amount at that
point in time. We hoped it would be worth more later but we
didn't put a lot of value on it at that moment but we felt
it was something that was important to do to have an
acceptable range with the UAW. And there is precedent for
this and my colleague Ron Bloom, my deputy had done a whole
bunch of steel industry bankruptcies and many of those
actually had VEBAs like Chrysler and in some of those cases
those VEBAs also got equity in the company as part of their
compensation and the restructuring. So, it was litigated all
the way through bankruptcy court, all through the court of
appeals, all the way to the United States Supreme Court and
essentially every judge said what we said, which was that
the key element is that every creditor got at least as much
or more than they were entitled to get or would've gotten in
a normal bankruptcy and the fact that some got this much
more than they would've gotten and some only got this much
more than they would've gotten isn't really a litigatable
issue. Everybody got at least as much or more than they
would've gotten and that's why we thought it was fair, and
there were no politics around it. Honest to God, I was never
told by the White House to do anything about the UAW other
than what we did. In fact, at one point Ron Gettelfinger
wanted to go in and see the President Rahm Emanuel and
basically they said, "Look, the auto team is doing this and
deal with them." Yes, Ma'am -
Thank you. I'm curious as to how your team approached
setting a new precedent as you went through this. You talked
a little bit about looking backwards at this had a precedent
but how did you think about what you were doing at the time
being a potential future model for similar cases?
Actually, we thought about it a lot and Larry Summers
particularly thought about in our behalf; maybe in the
opposite of the way you mean your question which was, we
really did not want to set a precedent for the government
intervening in the private sector. We all thought we were
pretty smart, we all thought we knew what we were doing but
none of us, I'm sure we didn't know as much as we thought we
did but in any event, none of us liked the idea that the
next group and the next group and the next group and any
industry could come in and say, "Do for us what you did for
the car companies," and get government money, we hated that
idea just the way we hated what my Vietnam analogy, just the
way we hated the idea of having a long term ownership
position in these companies, which is part of why GM went
public so quickly was for the government to be able to sell.
We viewed ourselves as investors of last resort. If there
had been any private capital that wanted to come in instead
of us, we would've said it's all yours. We didn't want to be
here or to do this. And so, our goal was to leave as light a
footprint as we could to be in and out as quickly as we
could, to have as little to do with running these companies
as we could, to have these private sector boards and frankly
to set as little a precedent as we could for future
involvement, because we believe rightly or wrongly, even as
Democrats, that the government to the maximum extent
possible should stay out of the private sector, especially
the industrial sector. We didn't believe that any of us had
the wisdom to override the kind of decisions of investors
and the market place and capitalists who were allocating
capital. We didn't thing the government should be doing
that. Yes, sir.
There was a case in 1980 that also applied for a government
bailout and received it. To what extent were you influenced
by that?
There are few cases. Chrysler, I think it was actually '79
or maybe it was '80 and Lockheed is one, Con Rail. There are
certainly a few precedents for the government stepping in
under extreme circumstances. We were not particularly
influenced by that early Chrysler precedent and I would
argue that each of those; I don't know enough about them to
evaluate whether they were the right or the wrong thing, I
would argue that I hope the people who made those decisions
in those cases basically made the same decision we made
which was systemic risk call it too big to fail, call it
what you want, that it was just too much of a risk to put on
the economy at that particular moment in time but again, I
think the number of cases like that is a small handful and I
think it should stay a small handful and I think it should
only happen under the most extreme circumstances and
hopefully, part of what I've tried to say in the book, what
I try to say in these talks and what we've said publicly and
the President said publicly is we just want this to be the
exception and not to have people feel this is not the long
arm of government, this is not creeping socialism, this is
not Obama Motors, this is sort of a decision that we had to
make but Bush, we hadn't have to make.
[Informal Talk]
Thank you for coming. Looking back on some of the past
government policies and protection policies; from an
outsider view do you think that some of these policies are
put in Chrysler and GM situation
[inaudible]?
Like what kind of policies?
Some of the trading agreements, protecting agreements they
had specifically in
[inaudible] went against Bush's free trade agreement and
business protection there, do you think that they are as
managed as those?
The whole thing; when I was a report at the New York times
actually I covered a little bit the crisis or bailout in '79
or '80 and during that period there was a lot of debate
about the Japanese and whether it was fair trade or free
trade and whether we would have kind of been taken for kind
of suckers or not and in fact, part of the reason that
Japanese started assembling cars here was that they were
afraid that we were going to put in import quotas on them
and therefore they'd be shut out of the market and so, one
of the reasons why they started assembling here was to avoid
that possibility.
Look, one of the things and this gets back to my management
matters theme of that article that you all have, one of the
things that struck me in the course of this is the fact that
GM had this huge problem. We put $50 billion into GM. GM
actually turned out in some ways worse shape than Chrysler
even though it's much bigger kind of company proportionate
to its revenues it got more capital than Chrysler and so,
here you have GM that runs for $30 billion in 15 months and
literally did show up having run out of money. Ford did get
into the trouble as I said; Ford had a tough brush, but Ford
got through it and Ford had huge profits last year, near
records profits last year and never needed a government
handout. And so, the question is why?
They are playing exactly the same set of cards, right? Same
UAW contacts, same Japanese competition or South Korean
competition, same oil prices, same credit crisis; so why is
Ford doing so well and Jim isn't. The only conclusion I can
come to is management. So, I can't tell you that every
policy decision the government made over the last 40 years
about autos helped or hurt whether it was right or wrong,
but I do think that a fair amount of the trouble that
Detroit got into was of its own making and the difference in
how the three companies went through it does reflect the
quality of management and the strategic decisions made the
long way. Yes, sir.
If it's true that management that you say that sort of
distinguishes whether an auto company is going to succeed,
why didn't the private sector step in earlier? I could
imagine like a private investor recognizing that there is a
depressing value in this particular management stepping in.
Is there any inefficiency in our take over market here that
sort of could have prevented this problem at an earlier
stage?
I don't know if it would've prevented the problem. I was
with you until that last part but we'll come back to it but
one of the things that Larry Summers and I used to debate
and I shouldn't be debating about anything but at least in
this one area I felt like we were kind of on neutral
territory which was the sort of efficient markets hypothesis
which actually Larry has argued both sides of it different
times in his career and I respect markets. I'm a private
sector guy but I also think markets don't always work and in
March of 2009, you could've bought Ford stock for a dollar
or something. It's now at $14 something. So there was a case
where private capital could've said, "This is a great
opportunity, let's come in," and they would've made a lot of
money. Even when we put $30 billion into GM; of the $50
billion $30 billion went in on June 1st when GM went into
bankruptcy and the first $20 was kind of lost, it has sort
of fallen over bankruptcy process. That $30 billion was what
bought us our 60% of the equity. If anybody had showed up
and said, "I want a piece of that $30 billion," we would've
said, "Great. Here, take it." That $30 billion today is
worth $40 - $45 billion. It's not ten times but it was a
very good investment that we made on June 1st. So, I think
markets can be inefficient and this I guess is good
questions that you all have asked about precedent and about
when the government should intervene; markets do fail and I
think we can debate the financial rescue, the bank stuff and
I have views about all that, but I think broadly speaking,
there are moments when government does have a role to play
when markets do fail, when private capital isn't being
allocated efficiently or intelligently and you see some of
that going on, Europe is going to face those decisions over
the next few weeks about what they do about Greece and
Portugal and Ireland, same kinds of decisions. So, they are
tough decisions, they are really tough decisions. I do think
that both the Bush administration and the Obama
administration really got most of them right in this case
but I think these kinds of interventions should be the
exception, not the rule. Yes?
[Inaudible]
I do think that the notion of trying to avoid the necessity
of government ever intervening by reducing every institution
to whatever it's considered to be the maximum size that
makes them not systemic is not practical. The example I like
to use is LTCM in 1998 was not on anybody's list of the 25
biggest institutions or most important institutions and it
almost brought down the whole financial system and required
a fairly dramatic intervention. The Canadian banking sector
is far more concentrated than our banking sector is and yet
they got through all this without needing the government
intervening. So those are two examples on either side of the
question.
Look, I think obviously a lot of mistakes were made in
deregulating the financial sector. It is too integral to be
allowed to just sort of run a mock and whether the Dodd
Frank stuff and all the pieces of it, the Velcro and so
forth are the exactly the right things or not, time will
tell but I think some of what we did was right but nobody
should kid themselves that either Dodd Frank or what we did
in autos or breaking these companies down would avoid the
need for government ever intervene. That's part of why you
have government, is to deal with extraordinary circumstances
and I've said a couple of times and I'll say it one last
time, what we should all hope and pray for is that our
leaders in the future are thoughtful about when they do
choose to intervene because I do think it should be by far
the exception and obviously when you do it, you want to do
it right as I said, I think both administrations have done
over the past couple of years.